home on the river Danube gained wealth
and prestige as a free Imperial City in
the 15th century the city went from
strength to strength its population grew
from 10,000 to more than 100,000 today
it's landmark is own Minster a tour of
the city isn't complete until you've
climbed to the top
we're now at the highest steeple in the
world we've got a height of 142 meters
even though there's a little further to
go until you reach the top at 160 one
and a half meters we've gone up 768
steps now the spectacular view proves no
steeple in the world is closer to heaven
building work on the Gothic church began
in 1377 and took five centuries to
complete it belongs to the people of old
who commissioned and paid for its
construction the relief shows the
groundbreaking ceremony where the mayor
and his wife hand responsibility for the
church's construction over to the master
builder that's why the reason after
today you describe it as a major act
they dug huge foundations and the mayor
laid the foundation stone in the pit and
took an entire year's salary and
guilders out of his clothing the
patricians followed suit
the women removed their jewelry and
threw it into the pit to pay for the
Minster that's moon starts with sun
carved into the oak choir stalls are not
only biblical figures but also ancient
scholars like Ptolemy
unusual for a church the eyes of several
of the figures were gouged out during
the so-called Builder storm or
iconoclasm associated with the
Reformation in the 16th century these at
this altar along with almost all the
others here in the O Minster was also
ruined in the iconoclasm after the city
of Ulm decided to become Protestant and
to join the Reformation the altars
mostly the altars I'm quoting the
councils minutes or chopped up and given
to the poor as firewood even the
Catholic Church became a Protestant
place of worship but it was still the
Minster belonging to the people of own
initially there was an outcry against
plans to erect a modern building
opposite the Minster the structure is
based on a design by star architect
Richard Meier it's changed the cityscape
of all this again they complement each
other wonderfully and what are you to do
you can't be building a neo Minster in
the 20th and 21st century that wouldn't
work at all we're living and building in
a different era now old and new works
together and nowhere as well as here in
ohm and that's the thing from the Middle
Ages to modern day home thrives on
contrasts that's also the case at the
vise helped kunst alla the art gallery
includes the personal collection of its
patron the businessman and art
collectors eke advice helped and also
showcases the work of contemporary
artists
the Cutts tala is directly connected to
ohms Museum in which a thirty thousand
year old sculpture is on display the
lion man is the oldest piece of
figurative art in the world
a fact that's not well known it's not as
famous as the bust of Nefertiti but it
should be because it marks the birth of
figurative art that's what's sensational
about this sculpture is a great place to
embark on a journey of historical
discovery visitors with an eye for
detail will even find Owens very own
sparrow perched proudly at the Minster
you